hello everyone and welcome back finally
at long last to binge battle it's a show
that we kicked off during that little
pandemic last year we had such a blast
doing it we said how are we going to get
this back who are we going to bring back
for the first episode what's the topic
going to be and now we are finally ready
to go i'm your host mark ellis and this
show is going to take you through
multiple rounds of spirited
competitive-ish debate about a singular
topic in this case it's going to be one
of the greatest sitcoms of all time and
we have two great guests here that have
very strong opinions about said show we
always love for our friends watching
from home to get in on the action you
can tweet me at any time at mark ellis
live or hit us up at rotten tomatoes
however you're enjoying the show we
appreciate you being on board it's going
to be a good one it's going to be a
spicy one and we're all going to be
tapping our inner unagi because that's
right friends is our topic and i have
two of my dear friends who are going to
be guesting and competing on this i'm
going to call it a debut episode of
binge battle we're rebooting it and
we're back and here is your very first
competitor she is not only a dear friend
of mine you also know her as the
co-creator and one of the stars of the
hit endeavor world girls you can catch
her on her daily show live at the roxy
and pretty soon you can see her in
theaters with her new film always lola
she is always a delight and her name is
roxy streier welcome back to binge
battle rocks ooh noggy i'm bringing a
heat today i have been preparing my
entire life for this moment or at least
since 1994.
come on mark this is like i was born for
this i was born i'm ready i'm nervous
i'm willing i'm able
have you ever gone so far in your
friend's fandom as to where the wedding
dress that we see rachel green wearing
in the very opening episode the series
debut i would say my prom dress was
pretty close mark pretty close thanks
david's bridal i mean i really i try i
do my best and i ate that ice cream on
the couch just the same
what was your first experience because i
know you're a little younger than i what
was your first experience with friends
were you catching it live or was it
something you caught later on with a
streaming service when was roxy stryer
introduced to six of her now best
friends yeah my parents didn't care what
age i was they were having me watch tv
right out of the womb so i watched this
with my mom growing up every single week
and this i i was watching in real time
and then i finally got to the age that i
could actually remember things and of
course had to get the friends vhs set
because we had all of the vhs's on tape
in my in the cabinet and then the dvd
set came out got that as well uh blu-ray
came out got that as well and now you
know you can get it anywhere so i've
i've been watching from day one and then
re-watching from day two three four and
so on
all right so if roxy wins today's
celebration party at her place bring
your own vcr we might need to borrow one
so roxy we're gonna meet your competitor
right now who also happens to be a dear
friend of mine he is the co-host of the
hit show blurred in the hood you can
also catch him hosting the citizen on
air app he's a talented actor comedian
and host and now he's here to talk about
his love of friends the one the only mr
winston marshall is back winston i see
that you're repping a different fandom
today but you are prepared and you were
made aware that this is a friends show
not a spider-person show you you do know
that this was actually ross's favorite
superhero i don't know if you knew that
so like you know i'm already in the mode
i'm in the mode man i'm ready to go uh
absolutely first of all thank you so
much for having me glad to be here
obviously great
great friends with you and with rox so
this is always fun when the three of us
get to hang out but i'm here to win and
you'll you'll find out like very early
on that even even my answers are tied to
how badly i'm about to win this like you
know what i'm saying like
friends has been a part of my lexicon
for so long it's one of those things
where it's like
it doesn't make sense how much i've
watched some of these episodes and i i
unfortunately did not have the entire
season uh on dvd or anything like that i
just had season four so there's a lot of
influence from season four of just
watching the same things over and over
and over again but eventually i did end
up getting five and six and some more of
my so i just had like the middle seasons
that i watched religiously and then
eventually once you were able to watch
it all over the place or if it was in
syndication obviously you'd catch other
episodes but
i'm i'm ready for it i'm so excited man
i would say that's arguably the peak of
friends is when you get into that season
four or five before
joey and rachel almost had a thing i
think right there in the middle is the
meat of that sandwich but what was the
first friends experience that you had
winston was it watching it live on air
or was it after the fact
i actually want to say it was from a
friend of mine it was in high school uh
so the show was getting closer to the
end of its run um but uh or like middle
school high school whatever and he was
like oh you watch friends and i was like
no he's like what do you mean you don't
watch friends he goes sit down and so i
sat down and i watched and i was like
this is hysterical
like this is absolutely ridiculous and
to this day
like a lot of people in the world uh you
know
you quote this all over the place at for
any point in time i feel like i've used
a number of these different uh quotables
throughout my life so i'm super ready
for it man i love people quote this show
when they don't even realize they're
quoting it like when i say could i be
more excited to be back doing binge
battle with two of these fine folks and
so as we get everybody here on the
playing surface it's so funny that roxy
brings up the vcr aspect of this because
friends debuted in 1994 and my family
instantly fell in love with it we got a
gentle nudge from my aunt who was
staying with us at the time she said we
got to watch this news show everybody
fell in love and we taped it one night
because we were at dinner we get back
and i hit play on it i guess i was the
tech person in the family and i fast
forwarded through the opening credits
and my dad got so upset because he's
like the song's the best part everybody
in the family was hooked on the
rembrandt was hooked on i'll be there
for you and of course the show that
ensued and so
here's how the show is going to work
today we technically have four rounds
but don't worry if it ends in a
two-to-two tie we have a tie breaker
round just in case i will be judging
each round each round is going to be
composed of three phases you'll each get
a minute to have your opening argument
and then you'll each get a 30 second
rebuttal period then you each also have
a final statement that you can close the
round with it's going to be a loose
minute and a loose 30 and a lose final
statement but i ask that you don't go
over a minute if you do don't worry i'm
sure i have some sort of sound effects
that me and our great engineer christian
can come up with so that's going to be
the way that it goes the winner will be
declared and then i want to make sure
that we part as friends just as we
entered and so i want to make sure that
we get all of your latest and greatest
streaming recommendations where all the
fine folks can find you after the show
because you're going to win over a lot
of fans today i might lose some friends
but you are going to be introduced to a
whole new world of possibilities
followers and pals and so with that i
say we start with a practice question
just to get everybody warmed up just to
get us ready to go get that that that
phoebe running stride down here it is
your opening question and again this is
worth no points i just want to get a
minute from each of you starting with
you winston
did you see the friends reunion and if
so
how do you like it
i did see the friends reunion um i think
it completely
it swept me off my feet in the sense
that like hey
a lot of them a lot of the friends
outside of anniston you don't see quite
as much so to see
where they're all at now is so
interesting obviously i know uh matt
leblanc's on uh he was on episodes for a
while and you know uh lisa kudrow's been
all over the place but like the thing
that really got me other than you know
jan is showing up and whatever
was hearing that jennifer aniston and
david schwimmer actually had feelings
for each other they could never act on
and i was like oh my god are also things
are gonna actually happen and like the
fact that that started to pop up in the
news that they were hanging out together
i i swear i completely was like
for like a good like couple of weeks
after that so it was wonderful man i
definitely recommend people watch it uh
roxy was that was that your big takeaway
when you saw the friends reunion
absolutely i mean if you are a die-hard
friends fan like winston and i are then
you can't watch that and hear jennifer
aniston and david schwimmer talk about
having feelings for each other and not
just like have your mind be blown but
one of the main takeaways for me was the
fact that this is just so ingrained in
pop culture that we have a fashion show
that justin bieber is performing in that
cara delevingne is performing in like
the that the biggest pop star on the
planet is coming to sing smelly cat with
lisa kudrow like that is insane there's
no other show where the m the biggest
celebrities out there right now are
taking back seats to the six friends
because this is
i i don't think that there's any debate
at this point this is the biggest sitcom
of all time and just seeing everybody
rally around this reunion
it made it feel like and all those
interviews of people across the world
i'm one of them like this changed my
whole life and so it just felt huge to
me
it's a must watch and honestly kind of
rude of you mark for asking winston and
i if we saw it like we're some kind of
degenerates or something
see look now i'm already excited hey
because y'all got your your your juices
flowing a little bit but also we already
have an idea for another binge battle
episode where we bring roxy and winston
back to team up to argue what is the
greatest sitcom of all time because that
is certainly that's a little spicy but
it's
hard to argue against it we'll table
that discussion and instead we will now
officially kick off binge battle with
round one here we go and your topic is
who is the best couple in the history of
the show friends
for that answer we first go to roxy
streier minute on the clock at your
ready
so obviously there are some main couples
uh that take place on the show the three
main couples being phoebe and mike
monica and chandler and ross and rachel
and so this really dictates what kind of
person you are what kind of relationship
you want to be in what kind of uh hope
you have for your life based on who you
choose as the best couple which is why
of course i chose monica and chandler
monica and chandler are the
quintessential couple of the show
because they're friends first we fall in
love with their friendship they are able
to
not only get through really challenging
times like having to learn how to
uh get rid of jellyfish stings and
navigate being somebody's brother while
dating their best friend and keeping it
a secret and all of those things but
they actually have such a beautiful love
story because that's kind of what we all
want at the end of the day you want to
fall in love with your best friend you
want to know that person inside and out
you want to believe in that person and
even though we found out there were
other people out there for monica like
richard um and other people out there
for chandler like janice
we find really at the end of the day
it's about these best friends coming
together they have the most beautiful
proposal of all time too with monica
getting down on that one knee and
chandler finally being able to commit to
somebody because it's the right person
so uh they have the the most incredible
love story that not only do you root for
but you aspire to have for yourself okay
i i like where you're going with this
too because you're kind of putting the
onus on everyone to say hey who you
choose as your favorite couple on
friends is a reflection on you as a
person and your own commitment issue so
when i say my favorite couple of all
time is when van damme flirted with
courtney cox for one episode after the
super bowl kind of shows you where i am
and who i am in life winston marshall
you now have a minute on the clock for
your best couple
go
all right so monica chandler is a great
choice i'm not going to deny that at all
but i wanted to go for a couple that is
a little bit more realistic to how most
of us and ultimately find love of course
the dream is to you know
that your best friend from high school
ends up
actually being one of your sweethearts
and the person you find as your soulmate
but phoebe and mike who i chose for the
best couple it starts off in a pseudo
meet cute because joey is being a kind
of a punk and he was supposed to set pbf
on a date and he goes oh yeah this guy
right here this is this is the guy
and it turns out that he actually ends
up being the perfect person for phoebe
and their relationship evolves the way
again most people's relationships tend
to evolve you start off on a couple
dates i kind of like this person it's
not so bad we get along you start to
fall in love
you're trading keys and all that kind of
stuff and then something major happens
that causes you to really evaluate your
relationship and that's that mike
doesn't ever want to get married again
he's already done it before but he
changes and become and makes that
compromise to be with the one he loves
because he knows that whatever you want
i want to give it to you and phoebe vice
versa so this is so realistic to how
most of us actually find our soulmate i
think that's why i have a tendency to
resonate more with phoebe and mike
knowing that it's a little bit more
natural than the kind of once in a blue
moon situation of the person i've known
since i was 10 is actually my my soul
mate
two great
couples and i think there's probably a
lot of people saying are we just tired
of ross and rachel did we just go
through so much emotional torment while
it was being teased will it walnut that
we're over that just as it happened that
is going to be on the back burner
because on the front burner we got two
great arguments so roxy going back to
you why are chandler monica a better
couple than phoebe and mike the thing
about phoebe and mike and you're not
going to hear me say a bad word about
anything about friends so you know don't
don't hold your breath for that but the
problem with phoebe and mike is that i
don't know that they're still together
today they don't stand the test of time
on this show and we've even heard the
creators of the show talk about the fact
that one of the reasons they didn't want
to do a reunion episode was that they
know based on the divorce rates in
america not all these three couples
would be together still and guess what i
think the one they're talking about is
phoebe and mike we already went back and
forth with ross and rachel enough monica
and chandler really we've seen that they
not only can grow together and build
together but they have children together
they move out of the city together i
mean they're ready for this life mike
and phoebe kind of all of a sudden
decide mike's like yeah okay maybe i
could get married again phoebe's like
wait i actually want a white picket
fence how long is that going to last for
we really just don't know it's a great
question winston how do you respond to
that 30 seconds well if we're gonna talk
about divorce it most definitely is
going to be either monica and chandler
or ross and rachel ross and rachel just
because as much as they love each other
that's one of those really passionate
kind of fizzle out monica and chandler
the thing is they do go through a lot of
their random ups and downs but part of
that has to do with the fact that
chandler as much as i love him and i
love him dearly can be kind of a lot and
so can monica and so i can totally see
you want to talk about a potential
divorce rate i didn't stop my parents
from getting divorced all right they had
kids and you know they split monica and
chandler very easily could do the exact
same thing based off of a lot of the
head butting they have phoebe and mike
it's one of those situations they're
both so goofy they're both so kind of in
each other's zone like that that they
they're gonna have their rough waters
but they're always gonna work it out
this is uh this is already why i have
the toughest job on this show it's cuz i
gotta make a call here final
statement about why your couple is the
best in the history of friends roxy
streier
phoebe keats keeps pet rats and mike
hates things like that whatever monica
does even having a closet of all of her
messy things chandler embraces because
at the end of the day he knows he cannot
live without her and is not going to let
her go
winston
mike's rich you think phoebe gonna give
that up she was homeless she ain't never
leaving that life ever again
she good she is very happy to be the man
that loves her most
this is the argument of practical
application versus just that feeling in
your soul that you can't get rid of i
had a girlfriend in college who had a
pet
tarantula we obviously did not last
together i was not the most enthused
about it especially the two times it
escaped its cage but we're still friends
to this day and so
really what this boils down to is what
do you want out of your partner do you
want unpredictability do you want this
could end tomorrow we're not sure if we
get along i'm not really sure what i
want out of life yet or are you more
like
chandler and monica where we've been
looking for our partner we've been
through many a
actor and actress that we've been
searching for that right chemistry and
we just haven't found it when the whole
time
it was right across the apartment hall
and so i think it's put up a great
argument for phoebe and mike but if this
show started out as us wanting ross and
rachel to get together it ended with us
satisfied that we got one couple that we
can bank on for the rest of our life and
that is chandler and monica i'm not
saying they don't fight i'm not saying
they don't argue all the time but
chandler and monica i feel like that is
the strongest fighter so
roxy streier takes the first round in
binge battle reboot history in a close
one over winston martial which means it
is winston who gets to kick off round
number two and for that the question at
hand
best guest star in the history of the
show and you both have made great points
about this show really in all of our
conversations since we've been buds and
talking about this program and i think
that for this segment guest star can be
somebody who popped in and out it could
be jean-claude van damme after the super
bowl you probably already get the point
but it also could be somebody who is a
little more recurring who popped into a
couple episodes here and there maybe had
a small arc so i want you to use your
artistic license here too give me your
best guest star in the history of
friends winston marshall you're on the
clock
now we've had a lot of really great
superstars really come on this show i
mean danny devito was the crying
stripper is amazing
obviously
obviously uh reese witherspoon and
christina applegate as rachel's sisters
um
so many so many great people but by far
the best guest star to grace friends
has to be brad pitt it's not even it's
not even close for a number of reasons
one
apparently all five of the friends in
one form or another have some sort of
weird crush on brad pitt as he shows up
because
what can you say he's hot it is what it
is right like chandler at one point even
stands up and looks at him and goes i
will come over and like hug you and say
hi but i don't want to compare your body
to mine like one of the funniest
comments that anybody can resonate with
if you met brad pitt but the fact that
this is a whole sequence
where brad pitt hates
jennifer aniston and this is before the
the divorce this is they are very
happily married at the time that this is
the the wife he loves more than anything
and his character hates rachel green is
the funniest concept and the most meta
thing that could have possibly happened
on the show
yeah it's not art imitating life it's
sort of life being the fun house mirror
of what the art is and lampooning the
real life it's a great call roxy streier
how do you respond really good selection
i'm gonna come for you in a minute but
before i do that oh wow the it's a
really good one though but the better
choice is bruce willis now let's talk
about a man that at this point was
already a
mega star we've already done die hard
we've already done pulp fiction we've
done armageddon we've done the sixth
sense we have made we've solidified our
place in hollywood as an a-list
celebrity major and then you come on
this show and you say
take me through the ringer you can make
me into the biggest
jerk and then also an absolute crying
mess whatever you want to do to me he is
in three episodes of the show and every
time we see him we don't know what we're
gonna get from him uh there is the
possible top three best moment on the
show with him uh i'm just a love machine
that is something that every time i
watch it makes me hysterically laugh we
get to see him interact with ross and be
a complete
jerk to him which is the best because
kind of all of us want to be a jerk to
ross at some point he's very annoying
we don't discuss this enough but he's a
very annoying character we get to see
bruce willis and jennifer aniston
totally make out thank you that gave me
a lot to
look at for a really long time i
appreciate you guys for that and then we
get to see this man completely melt down
and start opening up the floodgates and
start crying after sex and all of those
things i mean he is the greatest person
to be on this show and i wish that he
was on honestly for an entire season
because he deserved it all right so
playing against type with both of your
calls where we know that brad pitt at
the time was happily with jennifer
aniston going against that and then
bruce willis being this macho tough guy
that we knew from die hard in armageddon
and then all of a sudden we see that he
is a little softy inside after a while
it's a another good round we got going
winston marshall back to you for your
rebuttal why is your pick of brad pitt
better than bruce willis as a guest star
well i've already noticed that my friend
roxy apparently is drifting off into
space to call bruce willis an a-list
superstar and not brad pitt when we've
already gotten seven fight club snatch
uh he's he's right in the same year
ocean's 11 drops so he's already hit
that there's a reason people shrieked
when he showed up on the screen and it's
not just his looks but when you throw in
the fact that some of the story like you
any story where we get more backstory of
the friends and so we find out that ross
was also in the i hate rachel green club
the fact that brad pitt whose body is a
temple is freaking out about complex
carbohydrates his two greatest enemies
rachel green and complex carbohydrates
is again it is so
meta that it is it is insane it is it is
otherworldly and and i honestly i i
can't think of anything as much as i
love the
that is funnier than him slamming yams
on his plate because he's losing his
mind
all right we're going full metal with
the brad pitt roxy strea your 30-second
rebuttal i'm not saying brad pitt wasn't
an a-list celebrity but the
juxtaposition of die-hard bruce willis
and i can't stop crying after we've had
sex bruce willis it's just night and day
the fact that he would let them do what
they did to him on this show and okay
here's the problem with brad pitt i'm
gonna go in this isn't this isn't
necessarily his fault but this is an
episode that's called the one with the
rumor and oh boy does this episode not
age as well as i think they were hoping
for it what the rumor is is that
jennifer aniston is born with both uh
both sexual
body parts reproductive parts they
started a rumor about her that she had
both a vagina and a penis and everybody
is standing there talking that's the
rumor that brad pitt started and the
rest of the friends are there in the 90s
like
what are we talking about this is 2021
when you re-watch that it is like ugh
the other thing about brad pitt is that
he comes back and the whole thing is now
that he's hot because he lost weight
just doesn't play as well in 2021 for
the 90s for the early 2000s people might
have been laughing about that now this
episode it's not even the best
thanksgiving episode and yes the
thanksgiving episodes are incredible but
this while brad pitt embodies the
character well and he looks great the
actual episode that he's in is kind of
cringe at times
comedy and don't i know it doesn't
always age all that well so now we go
back to final arguments winston what do
you got
i mean if we're going to go out here and
talk about cringe and you want to talk
about weight loss does chandler not
infinitely make fun of monica for being
fat so if that's the case go ahead and
take your point back from last round if
that's the ammunition you want to use
but if we're gonna go here in all of
that situation one of the things that
you have to remember is it's not just
those cringe moments that make us go oh
lord it's everything else surrounding it
because if it was only cringe this show
wouldn't be what it is brad pitt
throughout the course of this episode it
steals the show we don't even really pay
attention to anybody other than joey
who's trying to finish a turkey by
himself and puts on maternity pants
this is brad pitt's show and they're
just all living in it and that is the
one difference with bruce willis he's an
add-on because his daughter's dating
ross this is about brad pitt that is not
a brock bruce famous thanksgiving
episodes all right rox final statement
and then i got to make another tough
call here
you're a neat guy
you are the man you still got it you're
still sexy you're just a love machine
you're just a love machine
it's a pretty nice way to drop the mic
on round number two that even winston's
got to give it up for you and i feel
like this argument sort of morphed into
a different topic where it's like what
episode holds up better than the other
one if you're just talking about the
best guest star
it almost feels like there was a fumble
on the field and winston just jumped on
the ball first because brad pitt the
fact that he was dating jennifer
anderson at the time or they were
married whatever their relationship was
that it totally played against type and
that was
must see tv
and i say that with a wink and a knot as
nbc nbc never had that slogan be more
accurate than when brad pitt was guest
starring on friends and so bruce willis
knocked it out of the park i love bruce
wilson there and for what it's worth i
love him and matthew perry in the whole
nine yards together but
i gotta give the point to winston over
bruce willis brad pitt and those sexy
abs and that lack of complex
carbohydrates gets the point here and we
need to work but also
oh wow
wait a minute we didn't even
we didn't even finish yet what do you
get out of here
you know i get it but exactly
it's getting good kids it's now moving
on to round number three and that is
gonna be
incorporating humor into
the sitcom friends funniest gag is your
topic roxy you took it on the last round
you get to rebound with your argument
first
well a lot of people
watched friends like watching individual
episodes and they'll say yeah i've seen
a few episodes
really friends was for the die hard fans
who for 10 years watched every single
episode of this show which is why if you
were watching for that entire time there
was something that stood out above all
else it's not only referenced in the
finale but all throughout the seasons
and that is
the alter ego of regina philangi now the
phalange
method is something that we get to see
constantly come and save the day not
only does she save joey multiple times
by uh pretend when he was pretending he
could speak french and she comes in as
regime falange and she makes it so that
he doesn't seem as absolutely asinine
and stupid as he is coming across when
he you can't speak french joey like come
on and she comes in and she saves him uh
she also saves him when he's trying to
be somebody's hands twin and she comes
in as regina phalangi to the poker table
she says i'm a businesswoman
those hands trust me i'm regina philangi
those look exactly like this she helps
chandler prep for his job interview
because she is regina phalangi
and at the end of the day at the end of
the season at the end of the series we
see her use the regina phalange which we
have grown to love through 10 years to
stop the plane so that rachel can get
off the plane because there is something
wrong with the left phalange so not only
did this gag make us laugh several times
not only does regina philangi somebody
that we're like wow we fully believe
that phoebe could do that because she is
just out of this world bonkers sometimes
but then it is the thing that causes our
favorite moment in the entire series
which is that rachel gets off of the
plane so it is the saving grace of this
show and it is the funniest gag
that was a great answer i was expecting
like ross's leather pants or his teeth
whitener but this is really getting deep
into the show and into the mythology of
friends winston marshall you got a tough
competition here
not really this is actually very easy
you like and i'll tell you why i'll tell
you why now
when you think about friends you think
about again what binds them all together
how well do they know each other how
much can they get underneath each
other's skin and i'm gonna say right now
uh you know season four as we mentioned
is right there the kind of the meat of
the sandwich here phoebe's
brother's baby
you know what i'm saying like all of
these amazing things all of it comes
down to
the trivia game it is so poignant in
fact that the reunion actually
structured most of the show around them
replaying the trivia game it's been
widely known that it's both courtney
cox's and matt leblanc's favorite
episode that they ever shot and it has
everything you would potentially want
out of it you get a little bit of a
teaser in act one when they're playing
with the grocery bag ross and his nerdy
self decides i'll write the whole game i
don't even want to do the thing but i'll
write the questions i'm here for it and
when did he when they were like we'll
get someone else he goes no no i'll play
i'll play like and then the competition
we find out about maurice the space
cowboy
miss
chenandolurbong like i could go on
forever and i will in my follow-up
argument but this is a solid moment that
if you want to show someone what is
friends you show them this episode and
you're like i am hooked
okay i want to stay with winston for his
follow-up argument because my follow-up
question is the way that roxy sort of
let us know that the regina philange gag
was recurring throughout it tell us more
about how the trivia game was able to
incorporate so much of friends war
within it
well for example the very the very last
question that costs the girls the game
is what is chandler bing's job and
they're just
something with numbers uh he's a trans
uh he does something with translating
that's right he's a trans he's a trans
monster that's not even a word like that
whole moment the fact that the apartment
is riding on it and for then half the
season the boys get to live in the
knights apartment and rachel is freaking
out from everything to the the singing
guy across the hall across the window
the mornings here we don't get any of
that we get zero of that if the girls
don't lose the game so by putting this
game with such high stakes and to see
how it flips and then even how the girls
get their apartment back
you can't beat it you absolutely cannot
beat it we got a lot of high stakes with
that trivia game because the apartments
were on the line there roxy so how do
you counter that with your recurring
regina falange i like a feel-good gag i
like something that makes me laugh i
like something that gets us that w that
victory i'm always rooting for the
underdog
uh and regina philangi is that what i
don't like is feeling devastated for
some of these characters this was a
really upsetting episode the trivia game
was crushing because you're no longer
rooting for the underdogs in what world
is it acceptable that these men
when the women are so crushed actually
go through and take their apartment it
is when you're watching it you're you'll
feel pain in your chest like i cannot
believe that this is happening so while
it is a good episode it actually led to
the girls losing their apartment which
was really hard to watch even though the
rachel not feeling okay with the
dropping of the food and the
everything that's taking place you feel
bad for them and you're just hoping they
get their apartment back which you know
is gonna happen because it's a sitcom so
the stakes are low but your feelings are
real and it's it sucks and it hurts
well let's be honest if you get either
one of those apartments in new york at a
decent price you're feeling pretty good
about that
winston going back to you final argument
to
stand the trivia game
the early part of this is is very simple
roxy didn't talk up about how regina
philange was better she tried to
downplay the trivia game so in the sense
that she didn't go well these are other
reasons why regina phalange is better
she was like the trivia game is oh no
and all that kind of but that's the
thing though we don't feel that bad in
the sense that like yeah you're like oh
dang poor girls but like the guys are so
elated there is an argument that is then
cut with the tension of phoebe being
pregnant and of course within what 10
episodes the girls get it back an even
funnier moment where they try to bet it
and they do it with some mixed tickets
but it ultimately just takes just the
the girls making out for five seconds
the guys will be like totally worth it
and then be like guys are so dumb like
it was so perfect the way from start to
finish during that episode and after how
it just brought everything together in
season four all right rox closing
argument thank you for the tee up
winston regina phalange is better
because this show had the wherewithal
to plant
about 10 different regina phalanges
scenarios the one with ken adams uh the
one with chan every single time they did
it it was a tee up to the final episode
thought of was one of the best finales
in any show ever in my opinion the
absolute best finale of any show and
that is the crux of the episode that
makes it all worthwhile with a 10-year
will they won't they relationship it's
all because of regina philangi so not
only is it the funniest gag but then the
payoff is bigger than any other gag on
the show
okay quick follow-up question for roxy
uh have you ever used the name regina
philange to
get into something has anybody ever
asked you what's your name and you
didn't feel like giving your them your
real name have you ever dropped the
regina for for certain i've said the
left phalanges broken when i don't know
what's going on how do i fix the
internet the left phalanges broken
there's nothing we can do
well the phalanges on this show working
just fine thanks to our lovely engineer
christian rubelkaba and
i had this as going to
winston in the trivia game
until that final argument swayed me
where
so much of this entire show was based on
calling back this one name that never
felt like it was forced or never felt
like it was tired and it was such an
impactful part of the last episode
and roxy did i think correctly say that
it's one of the better
series finales that you could ever get
because there's so much pressure whether
it's it's seinfeld or whether it's
cheers whatever it is
i think friends hit it pretty far out of
the park and the left phalange is a
reason why and so while i love the
concept of a trivia game determining
apartments amongst friends and i would
love to actually participate in that
someday and i think everybody here can
know how seriously we take trivia
sometimes but i'm going to need to
retire
i'm going to give the win here
by the skin of her phalange to roxy
streier so roxy congratulations you're
up two to one now but we still haven't
you regina at least one more round to go
because it's time for round four and
that is the question that we all ask
ourselves before we go to bed and when
we wake up in the morning
who's the best friend winston marshall
who's your best friend okay so you got
six phenomenal characters by far but
there is definitely
a tear
uh of these characters by like and i
would have to say the only s tier
character that we have out of the six
has to be chandler for a number of
reasons i think other than the fact that
whenever we needed some sort of joke to
cut the tension he was always there with
it he was always ready with a quick
remark always there with some smart
athlete thing there is not a single
character uh that has grown more than
chandler you can maybe make the argument
for rachel just because of where she
comes in but then she ultimate but like
at around when she kind of ends up
getting pregnant with ross's baby she's
kind of hit her peak but chandler
learned as
roxy so eloquently put before learns how
to commit he realizes he's in a dead-end
job that he hates so he puts everything
on the line in order to go and get a job
that works for him he
struggles with smoking a lot but we all
have our struggles and he deals with
that and then every time a serious
moment happened it was chandler that
gave those last words that made us go
dang
homie thank thank you for that so by far
and away chandler has run away with
being the best of all the friends
chandler bong is on the board roxy
streier how do you counter with your
best friend
there was a time
about
seven years ago where i was asked this
question and chandler was also my answer
but as i've grown
i've realized that chandler
is a very good friend he is in fact the
second best friend but he is not the
first best friend and growing up means
knowing that you were previously wrong
and you can now admit
that phoebe is absolutely without a
doubt the best friend
you talk about growth winston phoebe is
somebody who
we find out
her life story we don't know as much
backstory on any other character as we
do phoebe phoebe was homeless and this
is a co i want to remind everybody this
is a sitcom and phoebe is the funniest
person on the sitcom and this is her
story she is homeless she is abandoned
her mother commits suicide and she
carries her brother's child that is who
we are talking about as the funniest
character how an actress somehow managed
to make all of that
comedy i have no idea not only is this
is she the best friend on this show but
phoebe buffet and lisa kudrow's
performance as phoebe buffet is one of
the best characters we've ever seen on
any platform ever the way that she makes
us laugh
no matter what she's talking about no
matter what she's been through the way
that she doesn't judge anybody else the
way that this is a show in the 90s and
we had a character that was quirky that
was alone for a really long time that
went on plenty of dates but also hated
things like pottery barn like we this
was somebody we had never seen before so
talk about growth this girl went from
being homeless on the streets at 14
learning french in a behind a dumpster
to being
with mike
what what is that transit it's
unbelievable the amount of growth and
she's the best friend
all right this is gonna be a great
debate here because you picked my two
favorite friends of all time and i
vastly between who i love more daily so
winston back to you for a 30-second
rebuttal why is chandler a better friend
than phoebe i once again go back to his
growth i once again first point to the
fact that roxy clearly doesn't think
phoebe's that great of a friend if you
didn't think her relationship was good
enough to include in that argument early
up top and you went with chandler you
talked about how chandler really grew
into the man that we saw by the end of
the show that was so phenomenal but
let's talk about some of the other
really problematic things going on in
chandler's life that he actually stops
doing and becomes a better person
there's a girl he dated at summer camp
that he broke up with because she was
too fat and makes those jokes about
monica all the time and he has learned
the air of his ways and doesn't do that
anymore he is a much better person for
doing that you have a man that watching
his parents horrible divorce and finding
out that his father is gay ends up
saying some really awful terrible things
but at the end of it realizes not only
that that's his father and loves his
father unconditionally but starts to
accept and not be such a close-minded
essentially bigot if we're being honest
but you know what i'm saying so when you
actually look at the idea of how society
has evolved how we don't fat shame
anymore or we try not to we try not to
be homophobic chandler is all of us
making that giant step from being in
those dark ages to being really a more
well put together well-rounded person
that's accepting of everybody
seen a lot of personal growth and
character growth in this round roxy
i'll ask you the inverse why is phoebe a
better friend than chandler
when it comes to chandler
the one of the problems that you find
upon re-watch after re-watch which is
why he dropped the slot in my
book see now we never knew
what matthew perry we were gonna get
because he sometimes was showing up and
everything was landing and sometimes
when you're re-watching you're like
hello are you here today matthew perry
because it doesn't feel like you are
there was never a single scene that lisa
kudrow didn't show up for and i know
that i'm arguing for phoebe right now
but not only is she playing phoebe but
she's also playing ursula and and the
fact that she put so much effort into
phoebe in so many small minute details
that the second ursula walks in a room
even though it's lisa kudrow we know
it's ursula because
her her aura is different than the
character that she created for phoebe it
just shows how
layered phoebe is also when we're
talking about the best friend
phoebe is better at being a friend to
the other friends phoebe is the one who
tries to keep the marriages together and
when somebody's flying off to london
tries to prevent them from doing it
she's the one who tells all the other
friends the things that they don't
necessarily want to hear but they need
to as opposed to chandler who is always
messing with joey uh and just keeps
giving writing him checks but doesn't
actually support him in the way that he
believes in him he doesn't think he's
that good and it comes out in these
friendship bracelets uh i think that
phoebe is the better friend and better
at being a friend i did send winston a
friendship wrestling he has yet to wear
it uh winston your final argument hey
got it there we go um the woman
rappeller you
have your final argument it is upon us
you gotta stump one more time for your
boy chandler
to say that chandler is not a supportive
friend is absolutely chaotic and crazy
monica is chaotic and crazy with her
over organization and he supports and
loves that woman to he might put a
couple jokes at it but i don't know many
friends that i'm not poking fun at them
but really supporting them the same with
joey joey's acting career would have
been over
if chandler wasn't paying for head shots
and rent and everything that he did till
joey made it to where he needed to go if
you want to talk about just pure
unadulterated support there's that but
let alone the fact that he has been in
ross's life and ross is a lot this
entire time and still considers himself
so close let alone the fact that when he
had to give up for his new year's
resolution not to make fun of people and
he held that all in and let it let it
back out once again he is that real type
of friend that a thousand percent will
be there for you hug you love you let
you know everything's gonna be okay but
he's also gonna make sure that you stay
a little wise because the world is rough
out there and chandler makes sure that
you're ready for it
all right roxy one more time walk us
down phoebe memory lane no matter what
phoebe has gone through she shows all of
us that it's okay to find
love and laughter and humor and
everything and i don't think any of us
know people who have had a uh as
challenging or more challenging of a
life than phoebe the way that she's
presented to us is like this is a girl
who comes from severe trauma but every
single day she plays her guitar she
sings her song she doesn't care what the
world thinks she's fighting for
happiness and she also practices
forgiveness with everybody she gets
screwed by every single friend at some
point between
burning down her apartment or trying to
set her up with a stranger because
they're not paying attention she's
always giving more than she gets and she
still loves just the same she is the
greatest just the greatest
you know i i don't know this is a hot
take or not but i think i'm gonna safely
say that you could have ross and joey
chandler excuse me not chandler and not
phoebe but you're gonna have ross and
joey and you can have monica and rachel
and the casting department knocked the
show out of the park with all six
friends if we got someone else playing
those four roles
i still think the show survives and has
a great run if you get matthew perry's
chandler and you get lisa kudrow as
phoebe i think those are the two best
castings in the history of the show for
this reason that they both played their
jobs so well with chandler being the
funny witty one and phoebe being the in
their own universe so if you need a
funny person on a sitcom but you also
need somebody who's gonna be that kramer
who comes ins and out at their own whim
and just gets big laughs every time the
difference here is that i feel like with
phoebe there's a reason why phoebe and
mike is that relationship that is third
behind
ross and rachel and chandler and monica
is that it doesn't seem like the show
ever thought she was as essential as
some of those other friends and so while
i go back and forth between whether
phoebe or chandler's my personal
favorite friend
it's inarguable that chandler shaped the
sense of humor of an entire generation i
think a lot more than he gets credit for
because i see it in comedy clubs every
night i see a lot of phoebe in a lot of
comedy sense friends and i see a lot of
people basing their lives around phoebe
mantras but as far as being a character
in a sitcom where the goal is to get as
many laughs as you can in 22 minutes
i think i'm giving the edge here to
chandler so that also is convenient for
me because it just gives us a two to two
times now we get to go to our tiebreaker
round i made all my picks honestly but
now we get to a tiebreaker round so this
is how the hybrid round works it's a
little bit different it's not quite a
speed round but you each have one minute
to give you arguments and then i have to
render a verdict so i'm kind of putting
myself in jail by doing that but i think
we got a pretty good
sudden death topic for us here today so
round five is going to be about
what's the best quote in the history of
friends this can be some long soliloquy
i don't think i'm gonna get that with
either one of y'all today i think you're
looking for comedy gold the best quote
in friends history roxy stryer
you get to go first
it's not always that the most memorable
is the best
but in this case it is
if you ask anybody
what is what they think of friends if
they've never seen an episode they know
about ross and rachel and they know
that ross and rachel were on a break we
were on a break this is the debate that
people use for other shows people take
other shows and they say are they the
ross and rachel will they won't they
were they on a break we were on a break
is not only something that is used
throughout the entire show
from the second that they were on a
break and by the way we could get into
this debate all day at a bar wherever we
are were they or won't they i have
thoughts on both sides of that it is a
huge argument a huge conversation
starter for friends fans alike around
the world but not only is it that but it
also
provides so much comedy on the show that
in the finale episode as they're getting
back together and they're saying we're
gonna do this for real forever ross
turns to rachel and says
unless we're on a break and every
friends fan anywhere you were lost it
because you have feelings on this you
have an opinion were they on a break
were they not on a break does it matter
13 pages front and back it this is
something that we all
feel in our blood because you it's a
relationship show about this center
relationship and whether you believe
them to be toxic or not if you're a
friends fan you were probably rooting
for them and so this matters to you it's
the best quote it's the most memorable
quote it's a quote that people who've
never even seen the show know
and wizard behind the curtain here roxy
intimated having a bar conversation
about this like we're not going to be
arguing about this at a bar in a mere
matter of hours probably
[Laughter]
winston marshall it's i mean she picked
arguably the most memorable quote so you
got a mountain to climb here what is the
best quote in friends series history so
that that is definitely one to go up
against for sure but
there's two things that i think we want
to take away from friends at the end of
the day the first that we get just from
life in general is that sex sells
correct that's the one thing that you
hear all the time but secondly and more
important this show was always about
teaching us how to grow up how to adult
and i think one of the things that a lot
of men did not do well but especially in
the 90s early 2000s is to take into
consideration your sexual partners you
you were just worried about getting your
own thing off so by far the best quote
from friends
was the reason why is not only do you
get so many little nuggets you talked
about laughs per minute
so many laughs from like that's one
that's a pretty important one oh i'm
looking at it upside down sometimes
that's pretty good the number of laughs
just from that moment let alone with
monica be like a one two a one two three
a three four a three five a two four six
two four seven
five seven
six seven
seven seven seven seven seven and
rachel's over here like oh jesus
that moment made every dude go oh snap
first of all what are the seven i like
cuz because because chandler he's like
one two three goes cool set what wait
there are seven
like you know what i'm saying the simple
fact that that blew so many men's lives
and i guarantee made so many women's
wives better now because now men were
like have i really been screwing this up
so bad
it changed you want to talk about
changing a generation that changed a
generation
hopefully for the better in a lot of
cases and uh i mean i'm always
considerate in the bedroom just because
hey
i'm happy to be there okay i'm just
happy i got the invite so
friends has shaped us in multiple ways
and we've learned that once again here
today on this episode of binge battle to
render a verdict if it does apply to you
in a couplehood if you're trying to work
on your relationship with your partner
i'm definitely going the way of winston
here which is
know the numbers and know how they
correlate to your respective partner but
in the context of friends
there was one quote and it wasn't pivot
by ross which actually is one of my
personal favorites it was
we were on a break it's just that
exasperation it's that miscommunication
that is the crux of so many sitcoms
where i thought you were here but you
were here then wait then who's over
there it's always that oh i didn't the
ship's passing in the night we're not on
the same page you need conflict in
relationships it happens and in sitcoms
we need it to happen and it was never
better than that we were on a break and
what is the actual definition of a break
so whereas winston's quote probably
helped a lot of folks in the bedroom the
we were on a break conversation probably
got a lot of couples together but it
also broke up couples who were not
supposed to be together so we were on a
break is going to be the tie breaker
point roxy stryer gets the win and she
is your binge battle friends champion
but what a sterling performance by both
roxy and winston marshall
today i know it's heartbreaking to lose
because you both have clearly based your
lives around friends i think the only
way to do this better next time would be
to have you all back and we actually do
trivia and whoever wins gets their pick
of that person's apartment you all in
definitely um i would like to thank my
family for putting a eight inch screen
uh tv in the kitchen for me to watch
vhs's of friends before school every day
thank you so much for supporting me and
my dreams appreciate you
it's just one of the winston you you
took an l here today but who do you want
to thank for bringing friends into your
life
uh i got to thank my i don't know if
you'll ever see this but my homie
stephen chow i mean again i this the
show genuinely wasn't on my radar when
it first dropped but once i was uh once
it was made apparent to me i never let
it go from that point forward so shout
out to stephen ciao for you know being
like bro you gotta see this
it's an all-time great show and i'm glad
that people are are still new
generations are uncovering how much fun
friends can be because at the time
growing up with it around every thursday
it was everywhere it was like that 1989
summer when you saw batman everywhere
except you just kept getting friends
season after season after season and we
never really got sick of it so that is
going to be the result of today's binge
battle with roxy streier as your winner
so she gets to give us her streaming
recommendations first you can find her
at roxy streier roxy what are your
streaming recommendations and i'm
looking at some of your contenders it
seems like you had a lot to tell us
yeah have i mentioned that i'm alone
mark uh i i watch a lot of television
there's like so much tv uh on on
winston's point about people needing to
learn about uh sex and seven sex
education to me is just the
one of the greatest shows that's ever
been put out its third season was just
dropped and the fact that people still
are finding this show uh and and it was
just picked up for a fourth season too i
cannot
i cannot recommend the show enough do
yourself a favor but that's a show that
you might have heard of some shows that
i just kind of stumbled upon that i
didn't hear many people talking about
you guys know about schmegadoon
you know about megadoon yeah i'm gonna
say no this is a
cecily strong keegan michael key six
episode show that is so funny it's like
a a musical but a comedy about
relationships and
and it's just
oh i i cry laughing it's so funny oh my
god this is so good martin short is in
it kristen chenoweth is in it this cast
is an all-star cast and it's only six
episodes like you'll binge it so fast
it's perfect i remember seeing an ad for
that and i was like i love everybody in
this and so i might have to give this
one
a shot so those are two pretty good
recommendations winston is not a
competition anymore so you just feel
free to give your recommendation and
we're going to love it regardless okay
all right all right uh you know if
that's the case i was i was ready um i i
think the the the two main things that
i've been watching i've been flipping
back and forth right now um a lot of you
know the show originally was on fox got
picked up by a streaming service i'm
talking about lucifer the series finale
the final season is popping off right
now um and it's absolutely amazing um
you have to check it out um it is the
perfect send-off for all the people that
went out and campaigned to keep the show
on air so they could get the end of the
stories this is an incredible end to the
series and i absolutely love it um and
then the other thing i'm watching right
now is squid game um if you like
if you like hunger games if you like
battle royale if you like uh you know
parasite uh this is a korean thriller
that takes all of that and crams it into
one and you're just sitting there with
your jaw on the floor so you absolutely
don't want to miss either of those
cannot recommend them enough at all so
check them out
two good recommendation four good
recommendations from our guests here and
i'm just gonna go ahead and say it for
them they're also big fans of following
their respective football teams
currently winston the cowboys roxy the
patriots and so
i can't say best of luck to both of you
in your seasons you've been my
washington football team fandom but it's
just another thing for all of us friends
to debate about once we get to said bar
that's going to do it here for binge
battle make sure you're following us at
rotten tomatoes for all the latest
updates going on in the world of
everything from movies being released to
streaming shows to fun stuff like this
where we revisit some of our favorite
entertainment options of all time i'm
your host mark ellis that is roxy stride
you can find her at roxy strider that is
winston marshall you can find him at the
swaggy blurred for everybody here behind
the scenes our incredible engineer
christian ruvocaba our great producer
eileen i am once again mark and i have
to go feed my little marcel the monkey
molly the wonder dog so until next time
thanks for watching this reboot of binge
battle
bring it on